SO HERE'S THE SITUATION.
OKAY, YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR
WITH OBAMA IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL,
VERY COMPLICATED BUT
BASICALLY THIS IS IT.
EVERYBODY AGREES THAT IRAN
WANTS TO EVENTUALLY GET
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
RIGHT?
BUT THIS DEAL IS JUST TRYING
TO SLOW THAT POSSIBILITY
DOWN, IN CLASSIC CARTOON
TERMS THEY'RE TRYING TO
POUR MOLLASSES INTO THE
ACME CENTRIFUGES, RIGHT,
THAT IS BASICALLY WHAT THIS
DEAL IS LET'S KEEP IT 100
THERE ARE INTELLIGENT
ARGUMENTS FOR AND AGAINST
OBAMA'S DEAL.
AND THEN THERE'S THIS GUY.
>> IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED WITH RESPECT TO THE
IRANIAN DEAL, THE ONLY
WINNER ARE THE IRANIANS.
>> Larry: THAT'S RIGHT, DICK
IS BACK!
YEAH!
HEY, COME ON, GUYS.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THE WORLD WHEN
YOU LOSE JON STEWART AND
RETAIN DICK CHENEY.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: SOMETHING NOT
RIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT, JON
ACTUALLY WARNED ME ABOUT
THIS.
HE LEFT ME A LITTLE PAMPHLET
ABOUT HOW TO HANDLE DICK
CHENEY, HE DID.
IT'S CALLED JON STEWART'S
GUIDE TO HANDLING DICK.
(APPLAUSE)
PROBABLY NOT THE BEST TITLE.
THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
OKAY.
NUMBER ONE, MAKE IMMATURE
DICK JOKE, COMPLETE, DONE.
TAKE A FEW DEEP BREATHS. OKAY,
PENGUIN VOICE: OBAMA IS BAD!
OKAY, CHECK THAT
OFF, OH THIS IS INTERESTING.
IT SAYS SHOW ANY CLIP OF
DICK CHENEY, TRUST ME IT
WILL BE BULL [BLEEP].
(LAUGHTER)
NO WAY THAT CAN'T BE.
IT CAN'T BE THAT EASY.
ALL RIGHT.
ROLL ONE.
>> YOU COMPARE OBAMA'S IRAN
DEAL TO NEVILLE CHAMBERLAIN
APPEASING HITLER IN MUNICH IN
1938.
REALLY?
>> YES.
>> Larry: THAT IS BULL
[BLEEP].
JON WAS RIGHT.
OKAY.
SO YOU ARE GOING TO OPEN
WITH LINKING OBAMA TO HITLER,
THAT'S HOW YOU ARE OPENING
IT.
BILLY JOEL DOESN'T OPEN WITH
"PIANO MAN"
DID I JUST LINK PIANO MAN TO
HITLER?
SORRY, BILLY JOEL.
ALL RIGHT, BUT MAYBE IT GOT
BETTER FROM THERE.
WHAT ELSE DID CHENEY HAVE TO
SAY.
>> WE DID A LOT TO LIMIT
NUCLEAR PROLIFERATION IN THE
REGION
>> BUT THE
CENTRIFUGES WENT FROM 0 TO
5,000.
>> THEY MAY WELL BUT THAT
HAPPENED ON OBAMA WATCH, NOT
ON OURS.
>> NO, NO, NO, BY 2009 THEY
WERE AT 5,000 --
>> NO, NO, NO, NO.
NO, NOT-- HOLD ON A SECOND,
A FEW THINGS HERE, NUMBER
ONE, YOU JUST GOT CAUGHT IN
A LIE, OKAY.
NUMBER TWO, YOU DIDN'T EVEN
ACT CAUGHT.
YOU ACTED LIKE WE'RE IN SOME
SORT OF ABUSIVE RELATIONSHIP
WHERE LYING IS TO BE EXPECTED,
RIGHT.
WHATEVER, BABY, YOU KNEW I
LIED WHEN YOU STARTED GOING
WITH ME.
WHAT?
GO GET ME SOME COURVOISIER.
AND NUMBER THREE, AND
PROBABLY THE MOST IMPORTANT,
IF CHRIS WALLACE HADN'T
CALLED YOU OUT ON IT, YOU
WOULD HAVE BEEN HAPPY FOR
EVERYBODY TO JUST SWALLOW
THAT POISON PILL, RIGHT?
LIKE IT WAS-- A POISON PILL
THAT EVEN FOX NEWS CHOKED ON.
WELL, WHATEVER, IT'S JUST A
LIE.
>> THIS IS WHY IT'S HARD TO
HAVE AN INTELLIGENT
CONVERSATION WITH THIS
IMPERSONATOR OF A HUMAN
BEING.
MR. CHENEY, IT IS ONE THING
TO NOT HAVE A PULSE ANY
MORE.
BUT TO NOT HAVE A CONSCIENCE
IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
I MEAN GUYS, HE'S JUST LIKE
SOME CREATURE WHO JUST MAKES
[BLEEP] UP.
AND LOOK, I KNOW IT SOUNDS
LIKE I'M PICKING ON DICK
CHENEY, I KNOW, ACTUALLY I
HAVE TO ADMIT, SOME OF THIS
IS MY FAULT.
NO, NO NO.
I CREATED DICK CHENEY.
ALL RIGHT, OR MORE PRECISELY,
I SUMMONED HIM.
I KNOW.
I KNOW, I KNOW IT SOUNDS
CRAZY.
GUYS, GUYS, OKAY.
THIS IS A STORY I NEVER TOLD
ANYBODY.
AND PLEASE DON'T TELL
ANYBODY THIS IS JUST BETWEEN
US, AMERICA, OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO, I WAS LIKE
NINE AREAS OLD AT THE TIME
AND I WAS ON A-- I WAS ON A
HIKE IN THE WOODS AND I KIND
OF GOT SEPARATED FROM A
SCOUT TROOP.
AND THAT'S WHEN I MET THE
TALKING DOG THAT I FOUND OUT
LATER WAS A SHAPE SHIFTING
WITCH.
BUT THAT'S BESIDES THE POINT,
REALLY.
BUT ANYWAY, THE DOG LEAD ME
TO AN ANCIENT CAVE.
AND THEN HE HAD ME REPEAT A
SPELL IN A LANGUAGE I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND, OKAY.
BUT IN MY DEFENSE, THE DOG
WAS VERY PERSUASIVE.
YEAH.
>> SUMMON THE DARK LORD
FROM THE ETHER AND WILL YOU
GET LOTS OF TOYS FOR
CHRISTMAS.
>> RIGHT?
>> IF YOU HAVE EVER BEEN IN
THAT SITUATION, YOU KNOW THE
REST.
THE FIERY HELL, THE DEMON
MATERIALIZES, THE TALKING
DOG REWARDS ME WITH THE KICK
ASS CHRISTMAS AND EVENTUALLY
HE BECOMES VICE PRESIDENT,
INVASION OF IRAQ, BLAME
OBAMA, WA, WA, WA, SO SORRY
ABOUT THAT, MY BAD, ALL
RIGHT.
WHOOO, GOT THAT OFF MY CHEST,
MAN.
THAT'S GREAT.
>> JUST EMOTIONAL FROM THE
CATHARSIS, SO I APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT OKAY.
ALL RIGHT SO, DICK CHENEY
EXPECTS US TO BELIEVE HIS
PREDICTIONS ABOUT THE IRAN
DEAL WHEN PREDICTIONS ARE
SOMETHING HE IS JUST NOT
THAT GOOD AT.
>> SIMPLY STATED, THERE IS
NO DOUBT THAT SADDAM HUSSEIN
NOW HAS WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION.
>> Larry: NO DOUBT.
>> WELL, IF I COULD QUOTE NO
DOUBT, DON'T SPEECH.
>> AND IT'S NOT EVEN JUST
POLITICS, DICK CHENEY HAS
MADE HORRIBLE PREDICTIONS
ABOUT ALL KINDS OF STUFF.
LET'S LOOK AT A FEW YOU
PROBABLY AREN'T EVEN AWARE
OF.
>> I PREDICT BRUCE JENNER
WILL NEVER, EVER BE A WOMAN.
>> Larry: WRONG!
WRONG.
(APPLAUSE)
IT'S WEIRD.
KIND OF WEIRD HE WOULD WEIGH
IN ON THAT DURING THE '70s.
SO I THINK WE'RE ALL AGREED
HE GETS A LOT OF [BLEEP]
WRONG.
ACTUALLY, I NEED TO CLARIFY.
THERE IS JUST ONE BRIEF
MOMENT WHEN DICK CHENEY GOT
SOMETHING RIGHT.
IN THE '90s, HE SUPPORT THE
DECISION NOT TO INVADE
BAGHDAD.
>> ONCE YOU GOT TO IRAQ AND
TOOK IT OVER, TOOK DOWN
SADDAM HUSSEIN'S GOVERNMENT,
THEN WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
PUT IN ITS PLACE, THAT'S A
VERY VOLATILE PART OF THE
WORLD AND IF YOU TAKE DOWN
THE CENTRAL GOVERNMENT IN
IRAQ YOU CAN EASILY END UP
SEEING PIECES OF IRAQ FLY
OFF.
IT'S A QUAGMIRE.
>> Larry: YES, THAT'S RIGHT,
MY [BLEEP].
YOU PREDICTED THE VERY THING
THAT YOU ENDED UP DOING.
IS YOU KNEW IT WAS WRONG.
YOU KNEW HOW IT WOULD END
UP.
AND YOU DID IT ANYWAY.
YOU NEVER APOLOGIZED FOR IT
YOU NEVER ADMITTED YOUR
MISTAKE AND THEN YOU JUST
DROP LITTLE LIE BOMBS AND
YOU TRY TO MAKE THE BROTHER
CLEAN UP YOUR MESS.
YOU ARE LIVING IN AN EXTREME
COGNITIVE DISSONANCE THAT NOT
EVEN BILL BELICHICK WOULD
RECOGNIZE.
I DID NOT CONJURE UP BILL
BELICHICK, YOU GUYS.
ALL RIGHT.
NOW LET'S GET BACK TO
OBAMA'S IRAN DEAL.
YES, COMPLEX, YEAH, JUST A
LOT OF BAD CHOICES.
HERE'S FORMER SECRETARY OF
STATE HILLARY CLINTON'S
ASSESSMENT.
>> WITHOUT A DEAL, IRAN'S
BREAKOUT TIME, HOW LONG THEY
NEED TO PRODUCE ENOUGH
MATERIAL FOR A NUCLEAR
WEAPON WOULD SHRINK TO A
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
WITH A DEAL THAT
BREAKOUT TIME STRETCHES TO A
YEAR.
>> Larry: AND THAT'S SOMEONE
TRYING TO MAKE THE CASE FOR
IT.
RIGHT?
LISTEN, I DON'T LOVE THIS
DEAL EITHER.
BUT OFTEN YOU HAVE TO MAKE
DEALS WITH PEOPLE YOU DON'T
TRUST WHEN THE STAKES ARE SO
HIGH.
SOMETIMES IT AVOIDS NUCLEAR
WAR LIKE THE SALT TREATIES
WITH THE SOVIETS.
SOMETIMES IT GETS YOU A KICK
ASS BIKE FOR CHRISTMAS LIKE
MY DEAL WITH THE WITCHDOG
AGAIN, AMERICA, I'M SORRY.
BUT HERE'S WHAT UP SETS ME
ABOUT CHENEY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE ANYTHING HE
SAYS WHEN HE MAKES
PREDICTIONS, THEY'RE WRONG.
NOT TO MENTION HE KEEPS
PREDICTING OBAMA WILL LEAD
US INTO DISASTER WHEN ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST DISASTERS
HAPPENED ON HIS
ADMINISTRATION'S WATCH.
(APPLAUSE)
OKAY.
WELL I MEAN HIS AND VICE
PRESIDENT BUSH'S, SO-- SO
YES--
(APPLAUSE)
SO YES, I DO HAVE QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE IRAN DEAL, WE ALL
DO, BUT I TELL YOU ONE
THING, IF CHENEY'S AGAINST
IT, I'M FOR IT.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.